it's been one year since an internet
video of two brawling teenagers and the
man who stopped the fight went viral and
as Michelle Miller found out the fight
scene around the world and its peaceful
resolution have changed the young men's
lives and their New Jersey community in
the midst of an Atlantic City street
fight last March while young bystanders
recorded every swing neighbor oddly
Miller stepped in broke it up and gave
these teens a piece of his mind
Miller's lecture to this crowd went
viral now viewed more than 36 million
times words taken to heart by Sheldon
Ward and Jamar Mobley why is it
different because I never had a father
figure in my life
so was that comfort man and me it made
me look different like whoa for real
nobody told us just I don't know don't
find him it's not worth it he said to us
what a father was should have said yes
it's important you don't make your mom
and dad look like this yep what did he
tell you then he said shake hands and I
first wasn't gonna shake hands we were
still mad at each other he said he was
not leaving until we shake hands he was
literally lost and he wasn't gonna need
was not a smaller boat he still won't
leave the teens say he's the big brother
they both need meeting with them at
least once a week I was living a
nightmare but chasing a dream to help
them work through their own thoughts and
emotions
Rhymes and rap music our mutual therapy
now you to change the whole world and
then the whole world think is cool do
the right thing so you like the mayor
around here but I think I think people
you know people respect who respects
them well one thing that you will lose
their opportunities in life a father of
six himself Miller says he just wants to
help kids lead better lives once they
know that someone's paying attention
wants to know that someone loves them
once they know that people going to be
there for them and hold them to account
you know they'll rise to the occasion
what a difference a little attention
makes I just hated this pressure I just
want to fight this person and now we
call on each other brothers two former
foes now feel like family for CBS this
morning Saturday Michelle Miller
Atlantic City good for Ally Miller what
a way to bring a neighborhood back
together to show some leadership for
these two young men and really weave the
fabric of what blazed that so much good
has come out of one gesture it's really
extraordinary